Helicopters are impressive machines, but is
there an upper limit to how big they can get?
We spoke to this engineer at Boeing and here’s
what we learned: One.
Engineers are super into what they do, and
that is awesome.
Two.
The bigger and heavier a helicopter gets,
the more lift it needs.
The rotor blades are like spinning wings so
they have to do the heavy lifting.
Do we have an animation of that?
Yesssss.
Helicopters can create more lift by adding
more wing area, so a large helicopter would
need as long a rotor blade as possible.
But this creates all sorts of problems.
Helicopters can create more lift by adding
more wing area, so a large helicopter would
need as long a rotor as possible.
But this creates all sorts of problems.
For example, the tips of the rotor blades
can’t go faster than the speed of sound
or the turbulence will make the blades less
efficient.
The longer the blades get, the faster the
tips travel.
If the helicopter has an enormous and fast
spinning rotor, it won’t be able to fly
very fast because the blade that’s spinning
in the same direction the helicopter is moving
will be traveling through the air at its speed
plus the helicopter’s speed, bringing it
closer to that speed limit.
So, long blades would have to spin slowly,
but that would require a lot of torque to
move.
That torque strains the transmission that
connects the engines to the rotor, so to handle
it the transmission would need to be big and
heavy, and that’s a no-no.
Engineers could use shorter blades and add
more of them, but then the hub in the middle
of the rotor gets more complex.
Truly designing a giant helicopter is an engineering
feat.
Helicopters could get even bigger if they
used multiple rotors, and the V-12, did just that.
At 67 meters wide from rotor tip to rotor
tip, the prototype was wider than a Boeing
747.
It remains the largest helicopter ever built,
and proved that with imagination and engineering,
the sky is the limit.
For more epic stories of innovation that shaped
our future, check out TheAgeOfAerospace.com
Thanks for watching, don’t forget to subscribe!
Amy’s got the details on how helicopters
fly in the first place here, and thanks for
watching Seeker.
Hey can we see that wing animation one more
time?
Aw, yeah.
Uh huh.
That was expensive.